ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
MICHAEL KREMER: So I understand
that in the session
that you just had, you went
through the deworming case.
And I was just talking to some
people in the break, and they
were saying that everything's
been very focused on methods,
which is understandable.
That's what the purpose
of the course is.
But it sounded like people were
interested in hearing a
little bit about the substantive
results.
So I just thought before I
launched into this lecture,
I'd say a little
bit about that.
And maybe this is also a way
to give you a little bit of
background on where
I'm coming from.
So I taught secondary school in
Kenya right after college
and then went to grad school.
And then I went back after
graduating, from getting my
Ph.D. and getting a real job
and having some money.
I eventually went back to
visit some friends.
And one of them was working
for an NGO, which was just
starting work in
western Kenya.
And his job was to find seven
schools to start a program in.
And I said to him, not really
thinking this was something
that he would do, "Why don't
you pick twice as many and
choose the seven randomly, at
least where you're going to
start?" And much to my surprise,
he was interested.
And then he went to his boss,
and his boss actually did it.
So that's, in part, how this
wave of randomized evaluations
with NGOs got going.
This NGO worked a lot
on education.
And over the years, we tried a
number of things to try to get
more kids in school and stop
kids from dropping out.
But eventually, they tried
treating kids for worms.
And part of this was based on
reading the literature which
suggested that this is an
important health intervention.
There was a question, would
it have education effects.
So it turned out, of all the
various things that we looked
at, we calculated what was the
cost per additional year of
schooling generated.
So we're comparing a bunch
of things in that same
environment in western Kenya.
And deworming came out an order
of magnitude better than
anything else.
So this was a really
striking result.
If you spent $3.50, you could
generate an additional year of
education for a child.
It was just much cheaper than
any of the other alternatives.
So we had that academic
result.
There were people at the World
Bank who were very
interested in this.
There's a lot of heterogeneity
in the Bank, but a lot of
people there who are very
interested in and understand
evidence or are interested
in or responsive to it.
And the particular people who
are working on health and
education sector in the Bank
in Kenya, that very much
applies to.
So they then took it to the
Ministry of Education and
brought us in to talk
to the people in
the Ministry of Education.
This process took quite
a lot of time.
I don't want to underestimate
this.
Took a lot of time.
The first time, they said, these
results are interesting,
then, yes, we should
pursue them.
But there's a lot going on
inside the Ministry of
Education, lots of
other priorities.
There are teacher strikes.
There's all sorts of
things that have
to take higher priority.
But both externally, outside
in international fora and
academic fora, and internally
inside Kenya, we kept
bringing this up.
And eventually, the permanent
secretary, who's very strong,
the permanent secretary of the
Ministry of Education said,
let's do this.
And he brought in
various people.
And they decided they were
going to try to implement
this, have a national
scale up of this.
And there was both that internal
persuasion of people
within the Ministry
of Education.
And then, of course, there's
the question of
getting budget for it.
Obviously, having the World Bank
on side helped on that.
The other thing that
we did was--
so Esther and I were both
involved in an event the World
Economic Forum put
on in Davos.
And working with that group,
we were able to arrange for
there to be an event in Davos
on this issue of deworming.
And we helped start an
organization called Deworm the
World which was designed
to promote this.
And we invited the
prime minister of
Kenya to come speak.
And he made this announcement.
And I think that helped drive
this forward a lot.
Because once you got a public
announcement by a politician,
then it's really going
to happen in a way.
So between the support
internally within the ministry
and this higher level political
support, Kenya has,
just as we speak, just in the
past few months, dewormed
almost 3 million children.
So this is an example of how, if
you can identify successful
intervention, it can really help
promote scale-up of the
successful interventions.
Ultimately, that's the purpose
of what we're doing is trying
to improve policy.
So I just wanted to give you
that tie-in to reality before
plunging back into
econometrics.
Any comments or questions
on that?
AUDIENCE: I thought it was
really interesting.
Could you just give
us a couple of the
year points in that?
You talked about things
taking a long time.
Can you give more concrete
evidence?
MICHAEL KREMER: Our article
appeared, and publishing the
article takes a long time too.
Our article appeared
in 2004, I believe.
It's now 2009, and this
is happening now.
The NGO responded much
more quickly.
Although eventually,
they changed
their strategy as well.
So the NGO scaled up.
But to get the national
government to scale up, I
think that took a
constellation of various people.
It took some time for this to
get in the media, to get in
the academic world, to get out
to the media, to get out to
opinion leaders, both
internationally.
And then it took time for the
right set of people to be
available and the money to
be available to do it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just kind of
following up on that.
This is a issue that is
obviously quite concerning,
the bridge between academia
and the policy world.
And the fact that this research
is absolutely
fabulous, but then, at
the end of the day,
it stays in a textbook.
And what use is it
to beneficiaries?
This example is, again,
fabulous.
But what sort of actions or
roles are there to extend
findings into the policy
world and into
the development world?
I'm sure that's a big topic.
But just very briefly, is J-PAL
or sister organizations
doing that sort of extension?
MICHAEL KREMER: In this
particular case, I would say
that I spent a fair amount of
time afterwards trying to
disseminate this.
And J-PAL has been very
important in starting to
deworm the world.
I think this requires effort at
a variety of levels, both
in trying to get the prime
minister on board, but also in
trying to do tasks like, well,
you need a spreadsheet of
where are all the schools in the
country, and which ones of
them are in areas where we think
that there's worms, and
working out a bunch of logistics
of, well, how many
trainers do you need,
and so on.
Now I think in different
settings, they'll be--
in this one, people who are
at J-PAL and IPA have been
involved in even down to
that spreadsheet level.
That may not be the
case all the time.
I think it depends a lot on
the particular government.
I think, obviously, J-PAL
is primarily a academic
organization.
And so it's not the right
organization to manage the
actual roll out.
But where you draw the line,
it's a difficult question.
But I also--
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL KREMER: No, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So it seems like that
the deworming medication
is really cheap, and it's
a very easy treatment.
Have you looked at other types
of diseases and using the
school system to try
and manage it?
MICHAEL KREMER: Yeah.
So there are other things which
could be done in the
school health area
and perhaps with
micronutrients, et cetera.
I don't want to go too far there
both because I want to
get back to the econometrics and
because I know more about
worms than I do other things.
But I think there are
micronutrients and other
things that could be
delivered that way.
There's some work that's been
done on presumptive treatment
for malaria that is very
intriguing and suggests that
might work.
There's also things you can
do on education, HIV/AIDS
education, and so on.
Pascaline Dupas does some
very nice work on that.
And then Esther and Pascaline
and Samuel Sinei and I have
some joint work on
that as well.
OK.
Well, let me turn to the topic
of this lecture, which is--
and I'm happy if there's time
at the end or in the break,
I'm happy to follow up
on these issues--
which is managing threats to
evaluation and to data analysis.
So I think in the previous
discussion, there's been
things about how do you set up
your sample size, how do you
actually randomize.
Doing those things is obviously
critical, but it
might not be sufficient.
Because there can still be
problems with impact
measurement and analysis.
Some of those, you can try to
minimize ahead of time.
I'm going to focus mostly
on what can be
done ahead of time.
And then Shawn's going to talk
about what can be done in the
analysis stage to try and deal
with problems that did come
up, and what inferences you can
make, and what inferences
you can't make.
I'm going to do a small,
semi-randomized trial here,
quasi-randomized trial,
I guess should say.
I'm going to consider a program
which is giving people
money as a social, anti-poverty
program.
I think, rather than do
full randomization--
you can actually leave that
down for awhile--
I'll come back to the
evaluation of
this program later.
Now I'm going to do the
randomization and the
implementation.
And we can do the--
AUDIENCE: Too late.
MICHAEL KREMER: OK.
Too late?
OK, that's fine.
We could count off people, one,
two, one, two, and then
just give all the ones $500
and the twos nothing.
AUDIENCE: It really does
feel bad when you're
in the control group.
AUDIENCE: No sharing.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
AUDIENCE: This is real
money or this--
MICHAEL KREMER: Don't worry.
Well, you shouldn't feel
too bad if you're
in the control group.
AUDIENCE: I meant
cash or money?
MICHAEL KREMER: You've got
the money now, yeah?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
cash?
MICHAEL KREMER: Yeah, they'll
be opportunities later on.
OK, here are the problems
I want to discuss.
The first one is--
so hang on to this money, we'll
deal with it later on--
the first one is attrition.
The second is externalities.
And the third one is
partial compliance.
So the first one is attrition.
Some people you're not able to
collect follow up data on.
You try, but you're
not able to.
The second one, externalities.
What happens if your program,
as in the case of deworming,
winds up affecting the
comparison group as well as
the treatment group?
And the third one is
partial compliance.
You want to implement in certain
places, but some
places, they don't actually
implement it.
Maybe some of your
comparison group
accidentally gets treated.
What do you do in that case?
All of these things are really
about internal validity.
So there's important questions
of external validity and
interpretation.
And Shawn's going to talk
to some about those.
But I'm going to just
focus on the
internal validity of these.
So the first question with
attrition is is it going to be
a problem if some of the people
disappear before you
can collect the data.
And this can be a real problem
in Kenya for example.
Kids often change their name.
So it's just a part
of the culture.
You change your name
at some point.
That's going to make it
difficult to find everybody
afterwards.
So a first question-- oh gosh,
I thought this was going to
come up bit by bit.
Well, OK.
We got the whole slide.
So is it a problem if the type
of person who disappears is
correlated with the treatment?
And does anybody want to
answer that even though
there's some answer there?
This says the name of it,
but it's not saying
what the issue is.
Does anybody want to
comment on that?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So if the attrition
is quantited with treatment,
then you're going to end up
with underestimated or
overestimated effect depending
on what the correlation is.
MICHAEL KREMER: OK.
That's great.
Can you say more about that?
AUDIENCE: So if the correlation
is that the people
who disappear are people who
didn't get the treatment, who
most needed the treatment, then
what you're left with in
the control group is stronger
people, the people who maybe
didn't need the treatment as
much or maybe had other
reasons that they were
doing just fine.
And so it's going to look like
the treatment effect is less
because you have a strong
control treatment group
compared to a randomized
treatment group.
MICHAEL KREMER: Right.
OK.
So that's great.
So let's go through an example
where we can potentially see
that sort of thing happening.
So let's think about a problem
where there's some kids who
don't come to school because
they're too weak, they're
undernourished.
So imagine that's the context.
And imagine you start a school
feeding program, and you want
to do an evaluation of the
impact of this on school
attendance.
So this, in fact, was something
we wanted to do.
And imagine you're interested
both in the impact on
enrollment, but also on
children's nutrition, which
you measure by their weight.
And imagine that the real effect
of this program is that
the weak, stunted children
actually go to school more if
they're near a treatment
school.
So if you go to all the schools
and you measure
everyone who's in school on a
given day, in that case, are
you going to see the treatment
and control difference in
weight overstated
or understated?
AUDIENCE: Overstated.
MICHAEL KREMER: Overstated.
So what's the story for why
it would be overstated?
AUDIENCE: Because in the
treatment schools, a lot of
kids who really need
the nutrition
would start going in.
Whereas, in the control group,
they have no incentive to go.
So they're not being
included in it.
MICHAEL KREMER: That's
interesting.
That's interesting.
OK, OK.
In fact, the example is going
to be the opposite.
But I think it's true, you could
tell a story where this
could go either way.
And you just told a story where
it would go that way.
Let's show you a hypothetical
numerical example.
And if you can actually
work through this,
that would be useful.
Imagine there's just three
kids in each of these
communities.
So imagine that before
treatment, the distribution
looked identical.
So there was one kid who weighed
30 kilos, another at
35, another at 40.
And after treatment, let's say
it's a successful program, and
it gets everybody up
by two pounds--
I guess we should do this in
pounds given these numbers--
moves everybody up
by two pounds.
In the comparison group,
everybody stays the same.
So when you calculate, the
average here is going to be
35, and here it's
going to be 35.
So there's going to be no
difference at baseline.
If you look afterwards, if you
didn't have any attrition and
you managed to follow all
these kids, you would
correctly measure the impact
of this program.
You would say that it's added
two pounds to people's weight.
Now here's one possible
pattern of attrition.
Suppose you go on a given day,
but not all of the kids are
there that day.
So in particular, imagine that
the weaker kids are less
likely to be there.
So suppose only children who
are more than 30 kilograms
come to school.
Imagine the kids who are less
than 30 kilograms are only
there half the time
or something.
And you happen to show up on a
day when kids who are only
over 30 kilograms
come to school.
Well, then the person who is
still at 30 kilograms in the
comparison group isn't going
to be there at all.
You'll measure the average
here at 37 and a half.
So you'll see no difference
beforehand.
Afterwards, can you compute what
you're going to estimate
the impact of the
treatment to be?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's negative
half a pound.
MICHAEL KREMER: Negative
half a pound, right.
So in this case, for this
particular set of assumptions,
you'll underestimate
the impact.
It's not necessarily the case
that attrition differences
between the groups always
lead to underestimates.
It can be the opposite.
So we happened to pick a case
here where it worked this way.
But here's another example.
Let's put that other
context behind us.
Think about a different
context.
Think about the context
of we're just
trying to improve learning.
And we've got a new
math course.
And it's a hard course.
For example, in the state of
Massachusetts, there are now
graduation requirements.
Used to be that it was very
easy to graduate from
secondary school.
They put in requirements to
make this much tougher.
You have to pass an exam.
And the proponents of this
argue, well, it's a good thing
because it forces the kids to
study more, it forces the
teachers to really
prepare them.
And they're probably right.
The opponents argue that, well,
the kids who figure
they're not going to be able
to pass just drop out.
They may be right as well.
So if you're trying
to evaluate the
impact of this program--
and imagine that we randomized
across states in the US, and
some states implemented,
and some didn't--
if you looked at the average
score among those who got
through, well, you might
see it's better in
the treatment group.
But would that be the right
conclusion about the impact of
the program?
It might not be.
So let me keep going
with this.
So we've got this
harder course.
Imagine those who can't
handle it drop out.
You give the same
math test in the
treatment and control schools.
But you only have data on those
who didn't drop out
because you go to the school
and you get everybody who's
there in the school.
So what's the direction
the bias is going
to be in that case?
AUDIENCE: It'll overstate
the effect.
You'll only see the strongest.
MICHAEL KREMER: Exactly,
exactly.
In the treatment group, you'll
only see the strong students.
In the comparison group,
you'll have the mix.
So that's an example of
the case that you
were talking about.
In the deworming program with
testing, what was the natural
concern with attrition
bias there?
AUDIENCE: The weakest, the
ones with the most worms
weren't going to be--
MICHAEL KREMER: Exactly,
you get them to stay.
The kid's pretty weak because
they've had lots of worms.
You cut off the worms,
they come to school.
So the treatment group would
then be adding in these kids
who are weaker in some way.
So that would be the concern.
How do you deal with it?
Well, one way is you can try
to follow everybody up.
And this is the first thing
you should do is the brute
force approach, which is to try
and follow everybody up.
And that means if it's a school
program, maybe you
don't just test the kids in
the school, the ones who
dropped out, you try and find
them and test them anyway.
Now that's expensive.
And it's very difficult to find
people, and it may be
difficult to get them
to take the exam.
But if you think that the
program is going seriously
affect dropout rates, then that
can be a very important
thing to do.
To do that, you have to pick a
sample of those who are going
to be tested before the
treatment, and you have to
follow those people.
So if you hadn't done a
baseline, then this is going
to be especially hard because
you don't even know who
dropped out.
They might not have records
of those kids.
There's sometimes questions.
Should you do a baseline,
or should you not?
In theory, you could do a
randomized evaluation without
a baseline.
Almost always, it's much better
to have the baseline.
And this is one of them, which
is if the program might affect
dropout, you want to measure the
effect of the program by
looking at the people who were
initially in the program.
So then imagine that you do
that, but the truth is it's
just hard to find all these
kids who dropped out.
Some of them have moved, or
they're not home, or whatever,
or they don't want to
come take the test.
So imagine that you've done
this, and the treatment group
has 20% attrition,
the comparison
group has 20% attrition.
Are you then OK?
OK.
I'm seeing the answer, no.
Does anybody want to say
what the potential
problem might be?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, if it's not
random as to who drops out,
then we're just still going to
have to [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
facts.
If there's still a correlation
between who's dropping out in
the control group versus who's
dropping out in the treatment
group, that's still going
to affect the outcomes.
MICHAEL KREMER: Yeah.
That's exactly right.
I'm trying to think
of this myself.
Can anybody come up with a
hypothetical, but concrete
example, where you could have
the same attrition rate in the
two groups, but your estimate
would still be messed up or
biased, to use the
technical term?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: For example, if the
treatment group is only the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
could drop off and then
the control group is
[? losing flow ?]
would drop off, it's not going
to [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
MICHAEL KREMER: Exactly,
exactly.
So if, in each case, you lose
20%, but in the treatment
group, you're losing the top 20%
and the comparison group,
you're losing the bottom 20%,
and you only measure those who
remain, you're going
to be biased.
So here's an example of
something that could do that.
Imagine that you put in a
remedial education program.
Imagine you lower the levels
of the curriculum.
Well, then maybe the kids in the
treatment group, maybe the
kids who are at the top of the
distribution say, I don't want
to be in this school, I'm
switching to another school,
because they don't want the
lower level curriculum.
So you lose 20%.
In the comparison school, the
20% at the top don't drop out,
but the 20% at the bottom drop
out because they didn't have
this special attention.
So in each case, you've got
20% attrition, but the
estimate of the impact of the
program is going to be very
seriously biased.
So how can you deal with that?
Well, what you should do
is you should check
whether you have a--
imagine you had pre-test
scores for the kids.
Well, then you could see what's
the predictors of drop
out in the treatment group and
in the comparison group.
And ideally, you'd find the
predictors are the same.
And then you're somewhat
reassured.
You're not completely,
completely safe because maybe
your initial test scores aren't
really a good measure
of their true eventual
test score.
But it helps a lot.
The other thing you can do is
you can try to bound the
extent of the bias.
So we go through an exercise
like this in
the deworming paper.
So suppose everyone who dropped
out of the treatment
got the lowest test score
that you got.
So what you can do is you can
say, we're going to put those
people for whom we don't have
outcome data, we're going to
create an artificial data set,
where we put them back in the
data, but we artificially
assign them the lowest
conceivable score.
And then suppose everybody who
dropped out of the control
group got the highest score
that anybody could get.
So if you artificially give
everybody who dropped out of
treatment the lowest possible
score, and you artificially
give everybody who dropped out
of the control group the
highest possible score, well,
then you're bending over
backwards to say, how bad
could the program
potentially have been.
And if you do this exercise and
you find that even when
you do this, it looks like the
program is good, then you can
be pretty confident the
program's good.
So this is what's called
constructing the lower bound.
And similarly, you can construct
an upper bound on
how well the program did.
And if you have a high dropout
rate, your lower bound and
your upper bound are going
to be very far
apart from each other.
You're not going to be able to
say that much about what the
impact of the program is.
But if you have a low dropout
rate, it might be that your
bounds are very close
together.
AUDIENCE: And cheaper.
MICHAEL KREMER: It's cheaper
than fighting everybody, yeah.
I think a lot depends on
the particular context.
And there's also various
bounds you can do.
So let me not go into the
full detail on that.
But you can have bounds that
are very conservative.
This would be an example of
them, where this is very much
a worst case scenario.
You can imagine other scenarios
that are not the
very worst case scenario, but
are pretty bad case scenarios,
and say, even in that case, the
program would have worked.
The next topic is going
to be externalities.
But before I go on to that, do
people have questions on
attrition or comments on it?
Or questions about
this in practice?
OK, let me move on
to externalities.
So first, I want to create
some externalities.
So everybody who got
some money--
I heard a suggestion of
sharing some money.
So why don't we implement
that?
So why don't you turn to your
neighbor, and why don't you
share some of the money
with your neighbor?
I'll let you decide how generous
you want to be.
It is fake money after all.
AUDIENCE: Can we give to
multiple neighbors?
MICHAEL KREMER: Do whatever
you like, do
whatever you like.
And by the way, what you guys
just did, there are a lot of
theories of development--
I don't know whether this is
practice or not-- which would
say that that sort of thing
might happen, a lot of
theories about risk sharing
within communities, and so on.
Maybe that's all propaganda,
I don't know.
But anyway, some people would
claim that that sort of thing
can happen.
So now what I want to talk about
though is what's the
impact on our program
evaluation.
What I'd like to do is to do a
program evaluation now of what
was the impact of this
program, where
you're all a village.
I gave half the people
in the village $500.
So how did we do that?
Well, we pseudo-randomized the
program, reasonably close,
counting off one, two.
What's the impact
of the program?
Well, let's figure out how much
money our treatment group
people have and our comparison
group people have.
So if you can look in your
wallet, figure out how much
money you have there, add in
the fake money, and come up
with a total.
And then we'll try
and do some--
I'll do some data collection.
So let me put this up here.
AUDIENCE: Our actual money?
MICHAEL KREMER: Yeah, add in
your actual money and your
fake money, and we'll see.
So are you a treatment
group person?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MICHAEL KREMER: OK.
So how much money do you have,
including everything?
AUDIENCE: $784.
MICHAEL KREMER: $784, OK.
I hope there's no thieves
around here that I'm
revealing things to.
AUDIENCE: $784?
AUDIENCE: Including this.
AUDIENCE: Because I'm
a control group.
MICHAEL KREMER: You're
AUDIENCE: I have $300.
MICHAEL KREMER: $300.
AUDIENCE: [? Only money ?]
pounds [? away ?].
AUDIENCE: But these guys
gave it to you.
AUDIENCE: It was on your Charlie
card or whatever.
MICHAEL KREMER: So how
much do you have?
AUDIENCE: $407.
MICHAEL KREMER: $407.
And you're a treatment, right?
AUDIENCE: I got $14 and
$1 on my Charlie card.
MICHAEL KREMER: OK.
So $15, we'll call it.
AUDIENCE: $550.
MICHAEL KREMER: $550.
Maybe the second row
should just come up
and write on here.
AUDIENCE: $140.
MICHAEL KREMER: Sorry?
MICHAEL KREMER: $140.
AUDIENCE: $428.
MICHAEL KREMER: $428.
AUDIENCE: $318.
MICHAEL KREMER: $318.
AUDIENCE: $698.
MICHAEL KREMER: I'll
put this here.
AUDIENCE: $263.
MICHAEL KREMER: And are
you a one or a two?
AUDIENCE: I'm $500, I
don't know what--
MICHAEL KREMER: So
you're group one.
And sorry, what was
the number again?
AUDIENCE: $263.
MICHAEL KREMER: $263.
You're a very generous guy at
least with fake money, right?
AUDIENCE: $270.
MICHAEL KREMER: Oh, $270.
Looks like the program was
counterproductive in your case.
We had a negative seven
effect on income.
AUDIENCE: I have $227.
MICHAEL KREMER: $227.
AUDIENCE: $500.
MICHAEL KREMER: $500.
You know what?
We could go and do the full
sample, but maybe we should--
well, we'll take two more.
AUDIENCE: $700.
MICHAEL KREMER: I'm sorry,
which group are you?
AUDIENCE: Treatment.
MICHAEL KREMER: $700, OK.
AUDIENCE: I'm control,
and I have $200.
MICHAEL KREMER: $200?
Oh, so that got the--
We'll just take a partial sample
rather keep going.
Let's try and get the average in
the treatment group and the
average in the comparison
group.
AUDIENCE: The average in the
treatment group is 507 or 8.
MICHAEL KREMER: 508.
AUDIENCE: And the average in
the control group is 249.
MICHAEL KREMER: 249.
So now we do our evaluation.
And we go through, and
we say, OK, we
gave out $500 to people.
Now we've gone back to see how
they're doing, compare them to
the comparison group.
And it looks like they're
$259 richer.
So did the program work?
Well, the program worked.
But was it cost effective?
Not really.
Because we gave them $500.
They're only $250 approximately
richer.
This really wasn't
a big success.
AUDIENCE: Well--
MICHAEL KREMER: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: That's only one way
of looking at it, right?
MICHAEL KREMER: Exactly.
That's one way of
looking at it.
If you came with that
conclusion, you'd be missing a
really important dimension
of what the impact
of the program is.
Certainly, if you're a policy
maker who's mostly concerned
about what's the impact on the
community, not what's the
impact on the particular
individual I gave it to, then
you'd basically have a very
misleading answer.
So that's the danger.
The topic of this lecture
is what are threats.
And this is a threat.
You misunderstand the impact
of the program because you
haven't adequately accounted
for the externality.
That's the problem.
Let me now talk about what can
you do about that problem.
So let me look at this in the
context of deworming.
Then maybe we can come back
to this example again.
So in the case of deworming,
a lot of the earlier work
randomized deworming treatment
within schools.
So the problem is that when
you are dewormed, that may
interfere with the transmission
of the disease.
If the treatment kills the worms
in your body, that means
the worms are no longer laying
eggs, they're no longer being
spread in the community
as much.
So what's the problem that
that's going to create for the
evaluation?
AUDIENCE: You're going to see
benefits in the control group.
MICHAEL KREMER: Right.
You could see benefits in the
control group, just as this
cash example.
In this particular case, we
argue that those benefits
might not just have affected
kids who go to that school,
but might have also affected
neighboring schools as well.
But let's start out with the
analytically simpler case.
Suppose the benefits
are local.
So suppose you only shared money
with your neighbors, but
you don't share money with
people in another classroom in
engineering or something
like that.
And how can you measure the
total impact, the impact on
the community as a whole
of the program?
What could you do
in that case?
AUDIENCE: You could phase in at
different rates to try and
evaluate what would be the
impact of just having a
peer-controlled peer treatment
and then try and figure out
from the phase-in what
the impact of the
externality would be.
MICHAEL KREMER: So you
could phase it in.
In this case, if the
externalities were local
within a school or within a
classroom, in the case of this
money example, you could phase
it in at the level of schools
or of classrooms.
And say, we're going to do
20% of the people in that
classroom, 40% of the people in
this classroom, 60% of the
people in that classroom.
By the way, before I go further
with this, so there's
an advantage of this-- well,
let me come back to this.
I'm going to immediately assess
the advantage of this,
but there's also
a disadvantage.
So let's take this case where's
there's externalities
within a school.
So if we think about this
particular case, so imagine
that there's no externalities.
Pupil one is treated,
and the outcome is
they don't have worms.
Pupil two is not treated, but
they still don't have worms.
Some people just don't
get the worms.
Pupil three is treated.
They don't have worms because
the medicine worked.
Pupil four is not treated,
and they do have worms.
Pupil five is treated, and
they don't have worms.
Pupil six isn't treated,
and they do have worms.
So in this case, where there's
no externalities going on,
what's going to be the estimate
of the treatment
effect here?
AUDIENCE: 100% [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL KREMER: I'm sorry.
You said 100%?
Do you want to go through
the reasoning you're
thinking up on that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL KREMER: So it's true
that nobody who is treated has
worms because the
medicine works.
So the total people in worms and
the treatment group with
worms is going to be 0.
So in that sense, you've
eliminated 100% of the group
that does have worms.
How many in the control group
are going to have worms?
AUDIENCE: Three.
MICHAEL KREMER: Three.
So it depends how you define--
this is a big distinction
that people--
it's tedious, but it's important
to make when you
write things up is percentage
effect versus
percentage point effect.
So percentage point is
the absolute value.
So let me first do the
percentage point and then come
back to the percent.
So we have 0 people having it
in the treatment group.
The total in the control with
worms, was that three if I
remember right?
OK.
So 50% of people have it in the
control group, 0 have it
in the comparison group.
So it's a 50 percentage
point difference.
The difference between 50
percentage points and 0
percentage points.
So one accurate way to write
this up would be say we had a
50 percentage point
difference.
Another way would be to say,
we eliminated 100% of the
initial level.
They're both accurate.
It's just different ways
of expressing it.
When you write things up,
the convention is to use
percentage point for
the absolute value.
So the treatment effect
would be 50
percentage points or 100%.
But now suppose that you
actually do have
externalities.
So some children are not
reinfected with worms.
So these worms have a life
cycle, so eventually the worms
in you die.
You have a high wormload because
you're continually
being reinfected.
So think about this example,
where some of the kids in the
comparison group don't
get reinfected.
Let's just think about the
percentage point effect for
comparison.
What are you going to estimate
the impact being in this case?
AUDIENCE: 53?
MICHAEL KREMER: Right.
Did I just--
let's see this thing.
Let me just do the--
I'm sorry.
We didn't--
I think this other thing,
did we do the counting
right in that one?
AUDIENCE: Well, you said there
was 50% control with worms.
And unless I'm misunderstanding
it, it looks
like it's 100%.
MICHAEL KREMER: Yeah,
that's right.
Somebody had said 50,
and I didn't look.
I just assumed that was
the right number.
Let me just look at the nos.
Yes, that's right.
I'm sorry.
It's 100% who have worms.
Sorry, that was very
confusing.
So now I see why you said-- it's
100% either way whether
it's percentage points
or percent.
You would have reached
that same conclusion.
Let me just go back here just
to repeat, in case it wasn't
clear to others like it
wasn't clear to me.
So if the total in the treatment
with worms is 100%
in this example, total in the
control with worms is 0.
I think I must've got confused
in reading it in horizontal
lines there.
So in this case, the total
in the treatment
group with worms is--
we still have 0 in the treatment
group with worms.
And in the comparison group,
we've got 67%, 67%.
So we're going to estimate
the treatment effect in
this case being 67%.
Now notice that this--
AUDIENCE: 130?
Why?
Oh, because it's
the difference.
MICHAEL KREMER: The
difference, yeah.
The difference between
100 and 67.
Sorry, the hundred and--
see if we got this--
the hundred--
AUDIENCE: It's the total
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
0.
MICHAEL KREMER: This is
0, and this is 67.
So we've estimated 67% effect.
So the thing to take away from
this is that if there were no
externalities, we would have
estimated this correctly at
100%, the effect
of the program.
Now we say, suppose there are
externalities to this.
So now that makes the program
actually better because more
people are being cured of worms
through this program.
But we're going to estimate the
effect of the program is
actually lower.
Instead of estimating the 100%
benefit, we'll estimate only a
67% benefit.
So how do you deal with that?
Well, if you design the unit
of the randomization, so it
encompasses all those
spillovers, that's one way to
address this problem.
So if you expected all the
externalities are within
school, you can just randomize
at the level of the school.
So here's another approach.
And this is the actual data
from the program.
The percentage of children
with a moderate or heavy
infection in the treatment
schools was 27%.
It was 52% in the comparison
schools.
So the program reduced
moderate to heavy
infections by 25%.
This medicine probably affected
more kids initially.
But if you go back and measure
a year later, some of them
have been reinfected.
You also got a reduction in the
number of kids who were
sick and who are anemic.
This is comparing one school
to another school.
So we will have accounted for
the total impact of the
program within schools if
there's within school
spillovers.
Suppose you wanted to actually
measure the spillovers.
Suppose you were interested in
the spillovers themselves and
not just the total impact.
And you might well be.
Imagine you are interested in
the question of do we really
need to incentivize people to
take this, or could we charge
them for the medicine.
Well, if you thought that
everybody benefited from the
medicine pretty much equally,
whether you took it or not,
because most of the impact was
on the transmission of the
disease, then you might need
to subsidize it more.
You might want to subsidize it
more than if you thought the
individual got all
the benefit.
So if you actually want to
measure the spillovers, here's
one of the things we did in
the paper on deworming.
So at the time--
this is no longer the case, I
want to emphasize-- but at the
time, there was concern that the
official guidelines were
not to treat girls over 12
unless you knew they had
worms, they shouldn't be treated
presumptively in case
the medicine caused birth
defects and in case the girls
were pregnant.
Turns out, that they've now
given this widely enough that
WHO guidance is there's no
evidence it causes birth
defects, and you can give
it to everybody.
But at the time, they weren't
giving it to girls above 12.
So imagine you compared girls
above 12 in the treatments
schools to girls above 12 in
the comparison schools.
There are some other
things we can do.
So there are some other sources
of who wasn't treated.
This comparison I'm going
to show you is a little
bit more than that.
But you can compare the treated
students in treatment
schools to the comparable
students in
the comparison schools.
So kids who looked comparable
on a variety of observable
dimensions or who wound up
taking this when they became
eligible to take it.
We saw a very big gap
in prevalence
among those two groups.
So this is much more
of a straight
treatment comparison look.
Here, we're looking at the
untreated students in the
treatment schools and trying to
find comparable students in
the comparison schools.
I should emphasize this isn't
quite as pure as a standard
randomized design.
This program was phased
in over time.
These are the people that when
their school was phased in,
they wound up not
getting treated.
So maybe there were differences
between years, but
that's a caveat or a footnote.
So none of these guys were
treated, but these people were
in a school where their
classmates were treated.
So they have much lower levels
of infection than these people
who were also not treated,
but whose
classmates were not treated.
Now what if you expect
externalities across--
so actually, before I go on to
this further challenge of what
if there are externalities
across schools, just sticking
with this question of
externalities within schools,
talked about one way of dealing
with that was to do
the randomization at the
level of the school.
So what's the disadvantage of
doing the randomization at the
level of the school?
AUDIENCE: Assuming that
everybody in the same school
is at the same level.
MICHAEL KREMER: So you could
still have some differences
within the school.
But there is a sense in which
you're going to have less
information if you're
randomizing at the level of
the school.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You'd need
more schools.
MICHAEL KREMER: Yeah, right.
The crudest way of putting this
is if there's 400 kids in
a school and you have 100
schools and you're randomizing
at the level of the individual,
then you've got
40,000 observations.
And if you've got 200 schools
you're randomizing and you're
randomizing at the level of
the school, you've got 100
treatment schools and 100
comparison schools.
Much smaller sample size,
much less power.
That particular calculation I
just did is overstating the
difference.
You've learned about clustering
standard errors before.
But since there's a
lot of variation--
to come back to the way you
were putting it-- since
there's a lot of random
variation between schools--
some schools have good
headmasters, some schools have
bad headmasters, et cetera--
there's a lot of background
noise.
And it's going to make it harder
to estimate precisely
the impact of the program.
So you really have to think
about your particular context.
When you're thinking about what
level to randomize at,
think about, in your context, do
you think spillovers are a
real issue.
If you think spillovers are a
real issue, then you better
randomize at a higher level.
But if you think, in this
particular context, I don't
need to worry about it, if this
were a cancer drug rather
than a worm drug, then you
wouldn't need to worry about
it, and you're much better
off randomizing at
the individual level.
There might also be-- yes.
AUDIENCE: So this might be a
little too [INAUDIBLE], but if
you're worried about attrition,
would randomizing
at a higher level make that
less of an issue as well
because now you're looking
at a higher [INAUDIBLE]?
So if you lose individuals
within that,
it's still an issue.
MICHAEL KREMER: It would
still be an issue.
Yeah, it's still an issue.
So let's say that we've decided
we're going to randomize.
Take this worm example.
And we think that most of the
externalities are within
schools, so we're going to
randomize within schools.
We know that there might be
some externalities across
schools because this is an
environment where everybody
lives on their own
farm basically.
So you might have two kids
living next to each other, one
of whom goes to one
school and another
goes to another school.
That's not that uncommon.
So you could have some
externalities across schools.
But randomizing at the level of
a district would really not
logistically be very possible.
You'd have no sample
size left.
So you know there might be
some externalities across
schools as well as those
within them.
But you've already made the
decision to randomize at the
level of schools.
So what do you do?
Well, what you can try and do is
use random variation in the
density of treatment nearby.
So if you pick the schools
randomly that were going to be
treatment schools and the ones
that are going to be
comparison schools, there will
be some comparison schools
that happen to be completely
surrounded
by treatment schools.
There will be other comparison
schools that don't have any
treatment schools nearby.
So you can use that to try
to pick up how big the
externality is.
So that's what we tried
to do in this paper.
So here's a map.
So the ones are group
one schools.
They've been treated.
The twos are group two
schools, treated
in the second way.
Threes are group three
schools, now treated
to the third way.
Here's a school that's in the
middle of the lake which I
think is actually
on an island.
These schools in Uganda are
not really in Uganda.
GPS used to be intentionally
degraded because people were
wanting to use it for military--
it was developed by
the military, I guess--
they didn't want foreign
militaries to have it.
There are measured
with some error.
So we've got these schools.
So we can see there are some
schools that are near
treatment schools.
Other schools aren't near
By the way, the treatment
schools in this example I just
did here, the ones shared
with the twos.
But you could imagine the ones
might share with other ones.
So there could be externalities
on other
treatment schools.
Here's a group three school
that's all by itself and
doesn't have any neighbors
who were treated.
Here is a group three school
that has three group one
schools that are treated.
So would you want to compare
those to estimate what the
effect of the deworming
program is?
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't you use it to
estimate the impact of the
spillovers?
MICHAEL KREMER: Yeah, suppose
you were interested in
estimating the impact of the
spillovers, the medical
spillovers of treatment.
Could you compare those
two schools?
What might make that comparison
invalid if you're
trying to estimate the
impact of spillovers?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL KREMER: I'm sorry.
One means a treatment school.
Three means a comparison
school.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL KREMER: So
one's more rural.
Exactly.
This one is obviously in
a less densely settled
population.
This one, turns out these are
all rural, but this is
obviously much more
densely settled.
That's why they've got all these
schools around there.
So now in this particular
setting, why
might that be a problem?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because that area
might be internally different
from the [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL KREMER: Yeah.
So this is a disease.
I probably should
have said more
about this in the beginning.
So these worms affect one out of
every three or four people
in the world.
And they're spread through
fecal-oral routes.
They're spread through
fecal matter.
What are the odds that you're
going to get contaminated with
fecal matter?
It depends how many other people
are depositing fecal
matter in the environment.
Clearly, over here, there's a
lot of people nearby you who
might be depositing fecal matter
in the environment.
Over here, there
aren't so many.
So you might think that that's
how densely settled the
population is.
We don't think of Alaska or
the middle of the desert
somewhere being very diseased
environments.
But you think of a highly
concentrated place having a
lot more disease.
There's reasons to think that
sparsely settled places will
have different prevalence of
the disease than heavily
settled places.
So what we did because of that,
we didn't want to just
look at the number of treatment
school nearby.
We just talked about why that
would be a problem.
But we want to do that
controlling for the total
number of schools nearby.
So we control for the total
density in the area, total
number of schools within a
certain distance or pupils
within a certain distance, and
see what's the effect of those
schools being treatment schools
as opposed to being
comparison schools.
Oops, did I skip a--
OK.
So controlling for density,
what we find is that the
infection rates are 26
percentage points lower per
1,000 pupils in treatment
schools within 3 kilometers.
And then if you go further out,
there are 14 percentage
points per treatment schools
that are 3 to
6 kilometers away.
So this is controlling for the
overall density in the area.
So hopefully, we're abstracting
from that
particular problem.
So now suppose we want to
estimate the overall effects.
So let me come back
to this problem.
Clearly, we've incorrectly
estimated.
We estimated that only $250
of benefit went through.
But we think that the true
effect should include the
effect on the comparison.
In this previous case, we were
able to estimate the increase
in school participation in the
treatment group and then also
in the comparison group through
this technique that I
just outlined.
So we know in the comparison
schools, there's a 1.5
percentage point increase
in school participation.
There are three pupils in
control schools for every
treated child.
And in the treatment schools,
there was a 7 percentage point
increase in school participation
for all
children, but you only needed to
treat 2/3 of the children.
So you can then calculate what
the overall effect is of
treating one child.
So if you treat one child, you
pick up three children in
comparison schools, each of whom
gets a benefit of 0.015
additional years of education.
Then you pick up this is the
effect on children in the same
school, and you get an
overall effect of
0.15 years of education.
So treating a child costs
about $0.50--
in fact, it's probably cheaper
than that when done at scale--
but the impact that you're going
to get is if each child,
you get an extra 0.15 years of
education, if you treat seven
children, you'll get about an
extra year of education.
7 times $0.50 is $3.50.
You spend $3.50 on deworming,
and you get an
extra year of education.
Let me pause again here, and
I'll go on and discuss some
issues on partial compliance
and sample selection bias.
I'll get partway through that
topic, and then Shawn's going
to take up where I leave off.
But are there any questions on
externalities before I go on?
OK.
So you might think if you
randomize where the treatment
is, you're going to get rid
of sample selection bias.
That's not necessarily
the case.
So let me show an example.
So where you randomize where
you want the program to be,
that's not necessarily the
sole determinant of which
places actually get treated.
So let me talk about why.
So one example would be people
who are assigned to the
comparison group might try to
move into the treatment group.
I don't think this happened, but
parents could try and move
their children from the
comparison school to the
treatment school.
It's at least hypothetically
possible.
What are other possible reasons
why you might not get
this match between the initial
assignment and where people
wound up, where the people
wound up treated?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you might get
somebody treated, and they
don't want to take
the medication.
MICHAEL KREMER: Sure, exactly.
In the case of deworming, there
were some people who
either didn't want to take the
medication or who maybe they
wanted to, but they weren't
able to get the permission
slip to do it.
So that's one great example.
What are other possible
examples?
If you think about
your concrete
experience, imagine that--
I'll tell you a story
from our experience.
When this NGO was trying to
get started and they were
trying to pick the seven schools
where they were going
to work, they picked the
schools, and they had to go to
the government for permission
to start working.
And permission was slow.
It kept being slow and slow.
And they didn't realize
what was going on.
And it turned out, eventually,
that there was a politician
who was upset.
The NGO didn't understand why
the politician was upset.
Because one of the schools was
in his constituency, where
they were going to
start working.
Well, it turned out it was in
the part of his constituency
that voted for his opponent.
So in that sort of a situation,
what the--
I don't remember exactly the
timing of this, but what the
eventual resolution of this was
they started working in
the other part of his
constituency, where his
supporters lived as well.
So they're all sorts of cases
where you're going to want to
randomize, but you may
not be able to
have that happen perfectly.
In this case, it wasn't a,
quote, "legitimate" reason.
But there are other cases
where there'd be very
legitimate reasons why.
Maybe the need is very intense
in some area, and so the NGO
or the organization feels
it's very important to
work in that area.
So there may be lots of reasons
why some people in the
comparison group wind
up getting treated.
So there are cases like we
just heard about where
individuals allocated
to treatment
might not get treatment.
And there are cases where
people who are in the
comparison group
do get treated.
So in the case of deworming,
78% of those assigned to
receive treatment got
some treatment.
And the main reason they weren't
treated is they just
happened to be absent from
school the day that the
treatment was given.
Some students in the comparison
group were treated
because they went out and got
the treatment on their own
through clinics.
So what do you do?
Suppose this has already
happened.
So imagine you have data on
everybody, so attrition isn't
the problem, but
just the actual
assignment to treatment.
The assignment to treatment
and actual treatment don't
correspond.
So first, what's the problem
if you just do a straight
comparison, and what might
you do about it?
AUDIENCE: In this
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], say they
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] the students
who were absent just by
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] to their homes
and [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
MICHAEL KREMER: No, so the
program didn't do that.
So we talked about in the case
of the evaluation, when you're
trying to measure the test
scores or the impact on
attendance, you could-- well,
impact on attendance,
obviously, you find out whether
they're there or not
by visiting the school.
Unless you wanted to
do test scores, you
could track them home.
But the way the program was
implemented, those kids who
weren't at school that day
when they gave out the
deworming pills, they just
didn't get treated.
Maybe the program shouldn't have
been run that way, but
that's how it was run.
And there are reasons
why maybe it
should be run that way.
AUDIENCE: In the end, you
wouldn't be considering the
effect of actually
treating people?
You'd be comparing the effect of
intending to treat people.
MICHAEL KREMER: This is exactly
where we're going to
go, and it's where I'm going to
wind up and where Shawn's
going to be taking over.
Imagine you are interested in
the impact of this program on
test scores.
So one thing you might think
would be the right thing to do
would be to just look at the
people who actually were
treated and compare
them to people who
actually weren't treated.
That's going to be problematic
for reasons that
we'll explain later.
But let me follow up on your
suggestion which is if you're
a policy maker, there are
questions beyond this you'd be
interested in.
But you raised the idea of
saying, well, what's the
impact of the intent
to treat somebody.
And that is going
to be the right
answer to some questions.
So let me start with that
question, the relatively
easier question.
I'll let Shawn handle the
harder questions.
Suppose you're a policy maker,
and you're saying, look,
what's the impact of
putting in this
school-based deworming program?
Well, if you're interested
in what's the impact of a
school-based deworming program,
well, you know in
reality, it's a true thing that
you want to get at that
some people are not
going to get it.
If this is a school-based
program and you hand out the
pills at the school, tracking
kids to their houses who are
absent that day, that's
expensive.
That's hard to implement.
It uses too much
teachers' time.
You're probably not
going to find that
many of the kids anyway.
So you wouldn't actually
implement it that way.
If you're a scientist,
you do care.
But if you're the policy maker,
you might say, no, the
true effect of this program is
that I'm only going to be able
to get 78% of the pupils because
22% of the pupils
aren't there.
And if some kids don't
want worms--
don't want the medicine-- sorry,
if they don't want--
or maybe they do want the worms,
or they don't want the
worms, but they don't want
the medicine either.
Anyway, if some kids aren't
going to take it, then those
kids aren't going to take it.
So you might think, well, I want
to measure the impact of
this program in realistic
conditions.
And realistic conditions are
that not everybody's going to
be able to get it.
So let's suppose that you're
a policy maker.
Then what you could do is you
could look at what's called
the intention to treat estimate,
which is what's the
effect of the school having the
program or being assigned
to the program.
This comes up in medical
trials a lot with, say,
chemotherapy.
So some people who start
chemotherapy don't finish it
because it's just too
painful for them.
Or they're not able to
handle it medically.
Again, do want to measure the
impact of chemotherapy on
those people who managed to
get all the way through?
Well, not necessarily.
Maybe what you're interested
in is what's the effect of
being in this group
that tries it.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you think it
actually happened in 1997?
MICHAEL KREMER: So yeah,
I guess that actually
helps on the dates.
AUDIENCE: So it actually
is 10 years on the--
MICHAEL KREMER: That's right.
So it's 10 years.
It's 10 years before this was
rolled out nationally.
So yes, some things happened
before that, but this is a
long delay.
Yeah, so that first delay
of publication
took quite a while.
And then there was a second
delay after it.
Unfortunately, there's often a
long delay in these things.
Let me see where we are.
So what you can do is you use
the original assignment, and
then you're winding up with
what's called an intention to
treat estimate.
So what intention to treat
measures is what happened to
the average child who was in
a treated school in the
population.
So it's not saying, what
happens to the kids who
actually got the medicine.
It's saying, what happened to
the average child who is in a
treated school.
So that's the correct
interpretation of that.
Now is that the right
number to look for?
I talked about some purposes
where that might be the right
number to look for.
What would be some reasons why
you might be interested in
other questions other than the
answer to that question of
what happened to the average
child in a treated school?
AUDIENCE: You were thinking of
having a mandatory deworming
program in Kenya.
And then you want to know what
would be the impact if
everybody was forced to treat.
MICHAEL KREMER: Exactly.
So in this particular case, this
was a program where it
was designed in such
a way that not
everybody had to be treated.
It wasn't that you can't come to
school unless you show your
certificate showing you've
been treated.
But you might well be interested
in, well, what if
we went a step further.
And we said, we're going to keep
a supply of medicine at
the school, and if you are gone
that particular day, then
you get it the next day.
And we don't let you come
back to school unless
you take the medicine.
Well, you wouldn't
be measuring the
impact of that program.
Intention to treat is very good
if you're interested in
the narrow question of
what's the impact
of this exact program.
But if you're trying to go
beyond what's the impact of
this exact program, you're
trying to start to think about
generalization, then maybe you
want to understand some of the
underlying parameters.
And in this case, the underlying
parameter is what's
the effect on school attendance
of a kid who had
worms or a particular level of
worms no longer having that.
And then it's using that
underlying parameter that you
might be able to generalize what
would be the effect of
everybody getting treated, what
only some people getting
treated.
So to do that, Shawn's going to
talk a little bit about how
you would do that.
Let's do this example, where
we're trying to get the--
I'm wondering whether to skip
this example or not.
I'll do it.
I'll go through it.
In this example, if you look
at the people who were--
here's the intent, whether
there was an intention to
treat them.
So all school one, you tried to
treat everybody, but only
some of them got treated.
In school two, the intent
was not to treat that.
They were assigned to the
comparison group.
But a few people got
treated anyway.
And this is the change in weight
for each individual.
So then if we average the change
in weight, the average
change in school one--
I don't know if people want to
figure that out for a second--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHAEL KREMER: Sorry?
MICHAEL KREMER: So
it's 1.3, right?
And the average change
in school two is 0.9.
So the intention to treat effect
would be comparing the
1.3 to the 0.9.
Now when is that useful?
Well, that's what I'm saying,
for an actual program.
But you're not measuring this
medical effect that you'd want
for generalization.
Here is an example where it's a
malaria prevention program,
but there's political
pressures to treat.
And so you add.
Again, you can measure this
impact, this intention to
treat measure.
Let me--
I'm wondering whether
I should--
let me go back here and say--
Initially, the blue circles
were the ones that were
supposed to be treated.
I want to talk about why you
can't do what the apparently
obvious thing of just comparing
the guys who were
treated to the ones
who weren't.
You've got this malaria
prevention program.
40 villages are sampled.
20 were assigned to get the
treatment the first year.
20 were assigned to
be the comparison.
But some of the comparison
villages object to this, and
they say, we want to
be treated too.
And the program manager says,
look, we just have to go ahead
and treat this.
So if the program only gets
implemented in 15 villages, as
well as in 2 villages that
were supposed to be
comparison, so what do
you do to measure the
impact of the program?
So by the way, in the previous
case I mentioned with the
politician in Kenya, the extra
school was neither treatment
or comparison, so really, in
that case, there was no
problem because it was just
out of the sample frame
altogether, the extra school
that got treated.
In this case, some of the
comparison schools wind up
getting treated.
So how do you measure it?
Well, here's the problem with
what would happen if you just
did the naive thing and said,
we're going to compare all the
guys who actually got treated
to the comparison schools.
So we've got the blue schools
are the ones that were
supposed to be treated that
are in the sample.
The white schools are
other villages.
So T is the original
treatment group.
The T's are supposed
to be treated.
The blues without T's in them
are supposed to be the
comparison.
Now the actual treatment
are the green circles.
So you can't compare the
green circle villages
with the blue dots.
The green circles are the ones
that were actually treated.
And the blue dots are
the comparison.
Why can't you make
that comparison?
AUDIENCE: They're not
randomly assigned
from the very beginning.
MICHAEL KREMER: They're not
randomly assigned from the
very beginning.
And can you be more specific
about what your hypothesis
might be on the difference?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
that fought to get the
treatment would prefer some
help from the schools or
villages that were initially
selected randomly.
MICHAEL KREMER: Exactly,
exactly.
The guys who fought to get the
treatment might differ from
the ones that are initially
selected randomly.
They might have particularly
capable leaders, for example,
or influential leaders.
And those influential leaders--
this politician who
managed to get the NGO program
assigned to his area, he might
have fought to get lots of other
programs assigned there.
So we don't know whether we're
measuring the impact of this
program, or we're measuring
the fact that they're just
able to use their political
influence to get everything
assigned there.
And similarly, if you
leave out the--
So this is basically
just making the
point that you said.
The other thing that you could
think about doing is comparing
the villages that were assigned
to be a treatment
group and actually got treated
with the ones that were
supposed to be a comparison
group.
So what's the problem
with that?
AUDIENCE: Attrition.
It's kind of like attrition.
MICHAEL KREMER: Exactly, it's
the same principle, which is
you'd be leaving out a group
that is the ones who were
assigned to be treated,
but didn't
wind up getting treated.
Well, the ones who were assigned
to be treated and,
nonetheless, didn't get treated,
those might be the
ones-- so for example, imagine
there's violence in some of
these areas.
And your field workers can't go
there, so they never wound
up getting treated.
Well, the violence itself might
have had an impact on
development outcomes.
So you may be measuring the
impact of the violence or of
particularly bad leaders who,
despite being in the treatment
group, still can't get their
village treated.
So that's not going to be a
valid comparison either.
So one thing you can do is the
intention to treat estimator.
You can do that again
in this case.
So compare the initial 20
treatment villages with the
initial 20 comparison
villages.
And then you've got
the ITT estimator.
Now before I argued that the ITT
estimator, in the case of
the deworming program, that
arguably might be a very good
measure of some things.
You might not be able to do some
other things with it, but
it was still a useful measure.
But in this case, suppose we
want to actually understand
what the impact of the malaria
treatment program.
And we know that what's the
impact of it if you're able to
implement it.
Well, the intention to
treat estimator isn't
really telling you that.
It's telling you what's the
effect of being assigned to
the treatment.
But it's not saying what's the
effect of the program in the
cases where you're able
to implement it.
So that's a problem.
And that's where I'm going to
leave you with that problem.
And then Shawn's going to
tell you, at least,
a solution to it.